I was reading The Wall Street Journal as
I like to and I saw an article that said
why you should pick Virginia yes
Virginia in your NCAA tournament bracket
and then Poli comes in yesterday he goes
you know I got this philosophy here I'm
thinking of maybe taking Virginia even
though I know they won't win but then
I'm different than everybody else in the
bracket challenge
did you read The Wall Street Journal
Poli I am you know I'm not a subscriber
though it's a fine publication I saw it
afterwards when people said after my
thesis I just thought of coincidence
because you said you're taking Virginia
so Fritzi reached out to one of the
writers Ben Cohen for The Wall Street
Journal Ben what's been the reaction so
far on the recent article why you should
pick Virginia to win it all a lot of
people from Virginia thanking us for not
reminding them of what happened last
year mostly are they a value pick Ben
totally I mean they are the value pick
in this year's NCAA tournament and it's
because statistically regard the despite
what happened last year and despite what
happened last week in the ACC tournament
they have been the best team in college
basketball all year and in fact they are
one of the best teams in the last two
decades of college basketball
numbers-wise
and what makes this year's I mean you
always sort of want to look for the
value strategy in your bracket
especially if you have a big pool
because you know if everyone picks Duke
& Duke wins the chances are you probably
won't win because you have to think that
you're smarter at everyone else at
picking their early rounds and the other
teams and the chances are you're
probably not but if you pick Virginia
and they win and nobody else picks
Virginia you have a much wider margin of
error to win your pool and so you want
to look for these teams that are good
and undervalued and this year I mean
Virginia is is one of those teams they
are the best team in college basketball
and generally like the fourth or the
fifth most popular national champion in
in the big bracket pool so so there you
go who else is a value pick besides for
Virginia you know so the top three teams
this year are Duke UNC and Gonzaga
usually comes agha is one of those value
teams because people don't like picking
Gonzaga to win the national championship
but but not so much this year I mean I
think Michigan State Kentucky Tennessee
I mean there are only eight teams in the
big bracket contests that have more than
one percent of people picking them as
the national champion so if you want to
get really crazy and pick a team like
Kansas or Texas Tech or Houston I mean
all of those all those teams have less
than 1% of brackets picking them as the
national champions now you also have to
think that those teams will win the
national championship and I'm not sure
that's the case but Michigan State
Kentucky Tennessee I mean why not any of
those teams if I gave you you could have
the number one seeds or you could have
the number two and number three seeds
for this tournament what would you take
I think I would take the ones I think
that they are pretty top-heavy the
shooter and I'm not crazy about any of
the twos but I don't know what about you
I probably take the twos and threes I
there'll be a couple of ones that get
knocked off but I agree with you it felt
like this was a top-heavy tournament I
just can't imagine if Diane Williamson
wasn't in this tournament what what
would the interest level be there's
always interest because of the bracket
challenge but can we quantify what it
would be like if you didn't have that
star power of him because I don't think
there's anybody any other team or any
other player where you go I gotta watch
him except for maybe John Moore and no I
don't think so I mean III think that the
stars of the NCAA tournament are usually
the coaches I mean those little were
around from year to year and but also I
mean the magic of the tournament is that
in an hour - we'll be talking about some
teams some school that you didn't even
know existed until they sprang some
upset and suddenly they're the the story
of the tournament I mean no one expected
to be talking about UMBC
for a week last year or Loyola or Loyola
right I mean no one you know we you
wouldn't have expected to be to be at
that regional last year and to be
rooting for a 98 year old none right and
that's what the tournament always does
do you have any other tips with twenty
minutes to go before tipoff for people
just filling finishing up their bracket
don't pick Duke
oh don't how far it is doing no it
almost doesn't even matter I mean I
think the smartest thing to do is to
pick them to go pretty far because they
are really good but I mean you know
somewhere between 37 and 50% of brackets
and the big competitions the Yahoo the
ESPN the CBS ones are picking Duke to
win the national championship now part
of that is because ion and Zion is
amazing but it's kind of amazing because
there has never been a clearer strategic
incentive to hate Duke and yet people
are not really taking it I know
it's people are just for this year only
liking Duke and then they'll go back to
hating Duke next year well for sure and
you but you want to actually put your
money where your heart has always been
right and I'm speaking I went to Duke I
mean Andrew and I who wrote this story
for the journal about why it's never
been smarter to hate Duke we're both
Duke alumni however you know what you
want to win your office pool is you want
to pick Duke to get to the Final Four or
the national championship so you get
five or six more games of Zion before
the Knicks ruin him forever
and then you want to bet against Duke
because if Duke does lose and you're the
one person smart enough to bet against
Duke you're probably winning a whole lot
of money thank you Ben enjoy the
tournament we appreciate your time thank
Dan that's Ben Cohen he wrote the
article why you should pick Virginia
against Virginia in your NCAA tournament
bracket for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]